[Music]
slender man so slender man is a movie
based on the Slenderman urban legend
really recent urban legend - I don't
know exactly when it happened we're
talking past 10 years right wooden is
these four girls watch this creepy video
in the style of the Ring and they call
forth the Slenderman now they got to
survive it pretty much the jist lund way
to the scary stuff and what I like about
this movie there are some moments where
the camera turns and something creepy is
there and it goes but it's never like oh
something's creeping around the corner I
don't know then all sudden hey so we
still getting together for a study group
so I appreciated that I also really
liked the fact that for a large majority
of this movie you don't really see
Slenderman you don't get a good look at
him anyway promotion this movie what you
see is a shadow something moving in the
background something moved slightly and
the other person just bolts or maybe you
don't see anything at all maybe they're
just in the woods your mind's playing
tricks on you I really like that it does
change at the end of the movie but for
the most part doug is also in true
horror movie fashion as a horror movie
shut this movie relies heavily on the
sound if you don't want to be scared in
a horror movie don't close your eyes
close your ears
that's horror movie law I agree with Eli
Roth on that one and this movie plays
for that a lot of times it's sound
effects just it's this weird tree sound
effect which is great anytime a movie
can take a normal sound like just trees
being trees and turn it into something
scary that means after this movie if
you're out camping or something and you
just hear the trees you're gonna be like
but are they good on this movie for
making the audience forever question the
sound of trees this movie is a mental
breakdown is it really happening or are
they just going crazy but like it when a
movie makes you question that it's like
these people could just be going Craig
this must be what going crazy feels like
right interesting little footnote here I
like the fact that mythology and urban
legends they're rolling with our
civilization they're rolling with our
technology as we've become more
technologically advanced that urban
legends have become more technologically
advanced like Slenderman was never like
he's from Hell or something like that he
was never a demon or a dead guy or ghost
I always kind of understood it it's like
this dude might be a fourth dimensional
being that's what new mythology is going
to be now and going forward you kind of
see a little bit of that in Legend of
Zelda breath with a while the original
Legend of Zelda was more akin to
medieval lore you know you had dragons
and creatures you would see in medieval
lore breath of the wild some of those
creatures are in it but they're more
technology base their machines the
mechanical I really like that kind of
shows how technology and our meth all
it's blending it's changing the legends
as we go forward ready this is nothing
new horror movies have done this for a
while but as technology changed the
mythology had to change and there was
some stumbles along the way sure if you
like Slenderman is a part of that and I
feel like that something horror movies
are going to have to roll with going
forward like there's a cellphone segment
which I feel like is a violation of the
camera phone which I feel like is a
violation of 50% of people's existence
people live through that camera in their
phone maybe a separation of reality
there but if this movie can violate that
then ergo they have violated life for
some people which is great that's what
horror movies have to do like I said
before the intrigue mystery mind games
they'll kind of go away at the end the
end I felt overcooked it a little bit
flew a little too close to the Sun I was
like oh that's the Slenderman and that's
a lot of CGI in a movie with a budget
that can clearly sustain it so I wasn't
scared it wasn't creeped out I was just
like a look at the big CG I thought the
last words uttered in this movie are
quote yeah now kind of a weird line to
leave the audience with guys in the end
I felt Slenderman did his job you know
where the plots gonna go and it does go
exactly right there in a straight line
there's movies about four girls who call
the Slenderman who is now sequentially
coming after them how do you think
that's gonna go down guess what you're
right and that's I personally enjoyed it
I thought it was a good time the biggest
bummer is I know for a fact this movie's
not going to be playing in theaters by
the time Halloween comes out and
Halloween might be a bit too close for
this movie to be on blu-ray by the time
Halloween comes around it'd be a pretty
fun Halloween movie to sit around with
your friends and watch during Halloween
but we'll see what happens alright so
Slenderman have you seen it what did you
think about it the movie not the actual
Slenderman less you've seen the actual
Slenderman which case what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]